bonjour à tous donc je vais partager
avec vous un peu ma relation à la
créativité think out of the box
j'adore cette expression enfin plutôt
j'adorais cette expression parce qu avec
le temps j'ai changé quand même pas mal
de choses et j'ai changé mon point de
vue think out of the box c'est out of
the box c'est le cadre c il yad'énormes
il ya des règles il ya des habitudes que
l'on cumule au fil des années et c'est
pas évident de sortir complètement du
cadre et d'essayer de prendre des
risques de et d'aller voir ailleurs
ted les toques ted
on est dans un cadre pas évident pour
moi de rester dans ce cadre parce que
j'aime bien sortir
n'empêche que j'ai pas pu m'en empêcher
là sur une petite j'ai oublié j'oubliais
le off donc naturellement à la think out
of the box
je les ai rajouté en dehors du cadre
pendant pendant plus de dix ans j'ai
travaillé sur des sujets techniques
j'étais plus dans l'informatique des
sujets assez technique des projets
innovants des cons se construire de
nouvelles unités ou des nouveaux sites
de prod au côté informatique et à
l'époque j'avais l'impression d'être out
of the box et d'avoir pas mal d'idées et
tout mais en fait je me suis rendu
compte a posteriori que j'étais plutôt
in the box
c'est à dire que j'étais je restais
toujours dans le même cadre j'avais pas
mal d'idées mais je l' ai ramené
systématiquement dans le même univers
dans le même cadre avec les mêmes règles
avec les mêmes normes avec les mêmes
manières de
de fonctionner ce qui fait que en fait
au lieu de penser en dehors de la boîte
je faisais grossir ma boîte
progressivement mon cadre je le faisais
je le faisais évoluer progressivement
donc je montée en compétences et je
rajouter des idées que gens que je
remettais dans mon cadre je le faisais
grossir tout doucement
le problème c'est un cadre à force de
grossir il ya une inertie qui commença à
se mettre en place et ça devient de plus
en plus dur de sortir
donc il m'a fallu quand même une dizaine
d'années avant de me rends compte de ça
et après 10 ans là j'ai eu que j'ai
commencé à avoir quelques déclic et
notamment un des premiers déclic c'est
quand on est parti avec la famille à
singapour où la changement radical
on est nouvelle nouvelle tradition
nouveau mode de fonctionnement nous tout
est nouveau
donc pour le coup j'avais pas besoin de
penser en dehors du cadre puisque
c'était moi qui était en dehors du cadre
il fallait que je me crée de nouveaux
cadres et de nouveaux repères pour
essayer de me retrouver et depuis ce
temps là en fait j'adore créer de
nouveaux cadres sans cesse et donc mon
cadre à moi il n'est pas j'essaye qu'il
ne soit pas flexible et qu'il bouge au
fur et à mesure du temps donc ce que je
vais partager avec vous la c3 approche
que j'utilise régulièrement alors que ce
soit pour des besoins personnels ou
professionnels
parce que j'aime bien mélanger utilisé
c'est dans les deux environnements j'ai
partagé avec vous trois approches que
que j'utilise régulièrement alors la
première transposée l'idée c'est de
prendre de s'inspirer de quelque chose
qui existe dans un univers qui n'a
strictement rien à voir avec le vôtre et
j'insiste sur ce côté là c'est allé voir
vraiment quelque chose qui était
strictement rien à voir avec votre
univers et essayer de le transposer dans
votre univers dans votre dans votre
environnement
donc il faut que ça serve de sources
d'inspiration et là moi une de mes
sources d'inspiration c'est bon là c'est
une machine st
une machine pour faire des irm une des
sources d'inspiration seddouk dit doug
dit c'est un quelqu'un qui travaille
chez geely healthcare est qui qui
conçoit ce genre de machine et il en a
installé notamment dans des hôpitaux
pour enfants ou des hôpitaux et des
cliniques pour enfants et là il s'est
rendu compte d'une chose c'est que son
équipement au top de la techno style
fait ce qu'il doit faire sans problème
par contre l'expérience utilisateur
derrière il se rend compte que les
enfants qui arrivent dans la salle sont
en train de pleurer les parents sont pas
mieux le corps médical qui est quand
même un minimum a mis un minimum sous
stress et au final il se rend compte que
l'expérience qu'il donne à ses eaux au
client c'est une mauvaise expérience
donc là il a utilisé une approche qui
s'appelle le design thinking
bon là c'est pas l'homme pas parler de
la proche mais plutôt du côté transmis
transposition ce qu'il a fait c'est
qu'il s'est dit mais avec quel public
quel est le public qui a l'habitude de
fonctionner avec des enfants et donc à
proximité de là ou là où il est et il
est allé voir des responsables de musées
pour enfants et donc ce qu'il a fait
c'est qu'il a travaillé donc avec le
corps médical mais aussi avec ses musées
et les utilisateurs des musées donc
c'est à dire les enfants pour essayer de
voir comment il pouvait transposer le
les codes du musée dans un environnement
médical
qu'est ce que ça donne c'est qu'on part
d'une d'une machine de ce type là à
quelque chose comme ça et là au final
l'expérience est là plus rien avoir à
dire que là l'enfant heures dans le
premier cas de figure là on a une
machine et on vient faire un ennemi et
rem deuxième cas de figure là c'est plus
une machine qu'on a c'est une expérience
et donc on rentre comme comme on rentre
dans un parc de loisirs comme on rentre
dans un musée on a le l'ensemble a été
scénarisé et donc ce qui se passe c'est
que la nurse qui accueille d'enfants est
l'accueil d'une certaine manière là on
est avec un sous marin mais ils ont ils
ont fait la même chose
avec des bateaux de pirates avec dans la
jungle et ainsi de suite
mais par exemple sur le bateau pirate
c'est la nurse al riyadi mon attention
là tu vas rentrer sur le bateau pirate
il va falloir aller trouver le trésor
donc tout est scénarisé tout est mis en
scène et même sur hors jeu c'est pu
saisir sur celui là ou sur les pirates
ou l'entrée dans la salle c'est un petit
ruisseau et on a des petites pierres à
gauche à droite est donc double dit il a
fait un taux qui est super intéressant
là dessus dit il ya même des enfants qui
marchent sur les pierres qui se retourne
et qui regardent des parents en train de
marcher dans l'eau et di natale à temps
il faut marcher sur la pierre et donc
voilà
oui du coup l'expérience même si elle
est traumatisante
elles se passent d'une manière beaucoup
beaucoup plus intéressante donc la
première étape transposer deuxième
approche est donc là le fait de
transposer tout de suite là vous créer
un nouveau cadre vous changer
complètement complètement le vote cabré
vous est un cas de musée un cadre
hôpital vous en créez un troisième qui
est complètement différent deuxième
approche supprimer celle là je les adore
aussi parce que la supprimer c'est le
cas on n'a pas le choix on est obligé de
trouver une solution
et là ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce qui
m'a inspiré souvent ces sept cette
histoire ça c'est le satellite hipparcos
1989 donc son objectif cartographier les
étoiles il ya eu pas mal de pas mal de
soucis autour du lancement mon bref le
la fusée par et le satellite au moment
de se mettre en orbite géostationnaire
un des moteurs ne démarre pas ce qui se
passe c'est que le satellite au lieu de
tourner de manière géostationnaire il se
met à faire une orbite elliptique donc
là pas besoin de faire un dessin tout
l'est pendant plusieurs mois années tout
a été programmé pour faire un pour
tourner sur une orbite géostationnaire
donc là tous les calculs qui était fait
vous pouvez tomber à l'eau directement
pas ce qui s'est passé c'est que là ils
n'ont pas eu le choix
c'est soit on laisse on laisse tomber
satellite et on essaye de han han
reconstruit un autre mais bon là il y en
a pour
pour quelques je sais pas combien de
millions mais pour quelques millions où
on essaye de trouver une solution donc
là ils ont mis quelques mois mais ils
ont réussi à trouver une solution pour
régler à distance parce que l' inde est
un des problèmes c'est que vous rappelez
pas le satellite à la maison puis vous
fait les corrections dans le garage et
vous leur envoyez là il faut essayer de
faire les corrections à distance et là
ils ont réussi à corriger toutes les
problématiques donc lié à leur liés
aux réglages des appareils et ainsi de
suite
au final le satellite a tourné plus
longtemps que prévu il a cartographié
plus de 118 mille étoiles avec une
qualité supérieure à ce qui était prévu
initialement
donc le fait de se mettre dans une
situation ce que j'appelle no choice
c'est à dire qu'il ya un des paramètres
qui a été supprimé et là vous n'avez pas
le choix êtes obligés de trouver une
solution
les a permis de créer de nouveaux cadres
parce que là dans l'aérospatiale pour
être cadré ses cadres et parce que c'est
préparer vérifier sur vérifier enfin il
ya plusieurs étapes qui qui se passe
donc là ils ont été obligés de sortir de
leur cadre et de créer de nouveaux crade
de nouveaux cadres et découvrir de
nouvelles de nouvelles opportunités ce
qu'ils ont fait de manière de manière
superbe troisième approche osé à bientôt
bientôt leur pain et les glaces aux
hélas elle les germes légèrement
différente de supprimer ce que supprimer
on n'a pas le choix on est obligé de
trouver une solution aux et là c'est de
dire on à l'avs on a la ligne blanche
on a le choix mais on prend le choix de
notre de franchir cette ligne blanche et
cette histoire là c'est l'histoire de
monsieur madame mathus en 1961 qui
qui avait pour pour idée de monter une
société qui vend des glaces et à cette
époque en 1961 dans s'appuie énormément
sur des études de marché et ainsi de
suite
et donc ils ont fait comme tout le monde
ils se sont appuyés sur une étude de
marché qui donnait essentiellement cinq
critères à suivre donc sur parmi les
critères à suivre il y avait à voir des
glaces qui soit peu coûteuse à voir
notamment des dégoûts qui soit simple et
bon il ya eu 5 mai le troisième que je
vais prendre c'est avoir un nom facile à
prononcer et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
monsieur madame à tous ils ont pris
l'étude de marché ont fait exactement
l'opposé donc à votre avis quelle est la
société qui existe toujours
exactement voilà donc en 1961 il va il
fallait quand même oser dire je pars
d'une étude de marché je suis exactement
l'opposé
et qu'est-ce que quoi qu'on me dise je
fais l'inversé et salah il avait le
choix
vous avez le choix soit de suivre soit
de sodas les rencontres et ça c'est
intéressant parce que dès qu'on prend le
pas doser le plus dur c'est de faire le
premier pas une fois que vous l'avez
fait de façon le pied dedans il faut y
aller et c'est là où vous pouvez
découvrir pas mal de pas mal de choses
donc ces trois approches je les utilise
je les utilise couramment mais le
problème c'est de l'expliquer
l'expliquez vous allez me dire ou es ok
et je voulais trouver une solution pour
parce que des images ou des fins d
images parlent pour moi elle ça parle
plus que des mots des fois dont je vous
ai trouvé un exercice qui permettent de
mettre en exergue le set cette partie là
donc il ya trois quatre ans j'ai créé un
petit exercice j'appelle le test de la
chaise non parce que là je vous ai
dessiné une chaise en deux dimensions
vue de profil et la consigne c'est
pouvez vous transformer ce dessin où
quelque chose qui se déplace
donc je voulais 500 est assez bien j'ai
un chrono donc je voulais 5 secondes
réfléchissez un petit peu quand je le
fais avec une population on va dire
comme comme la vôtre
alors j'ai des idées super intéressante
il ya plein de choses qui arrivent mais
systématiquement j'ai à peu près 30% des
gens qui vont faire quelque chose comme
ça c'est à dire j'ai une chaise au
départ la consigne je parle comme dans
la consigne je parle pas de chaise
le dit pouvez-vous me transformer ce
dessin où quelque chose qui se déplace
chez eux au minimum 30 % des personnes
qui vont ajouter les roues je fais le
même exercice avec des enfants donc
enfant plutôt primaire maternelle ou
primaire mais ça marche un peu mieux
avec avec les primaires et là il ya
hawks t il ya deux ans j'ai eu une une
fille qui était en
à l'époque elle devait être en c1 ou ce2
s'appelle pauline qui m'a pris la
feuille de dessin et en moins de 5
secondes m'a dessiné ça dans le premier
cas de figure la consigne respectée
la chaise se déplace on sort pas du
cadre
deuxième cas de figure la consigne est
toujours respectée parce que le bonhomme
peut se déplacer et là elle est sortie
du cadre
quand je vous parle de transposer de
osez il ya plein de choses qui sont
derrière c'est à dire que là il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas de peur au niveau
du jugement de l'autre ou quoi que ce
soit elle son instinct c'est de partir
là dessus je suis parti là dessus est en
fait la grosse différence qu'il est
qu'il y as entre les entre les deux les
deux univers c'est que pauline quand
elle quand elle a fait ça elle a
complètement oublié la chaise
c'est à dire quand je lui ai donné la
consigne transforme moi ce dessin où
quelque chose qui se déplace elle a pas
vu une chaise avait vu trois bâtons et
je continue mon dessin alors que quand
j'ai fait le jeu fait l'exercice avec
les adultes y en a certains je peux vous
dire qu'ils sont accrochés à la chaise
et qui ne veulent pas sortir de la
chaise
donc du coup quand j'ai vu ça je me suis
dit je vais faire une petite variante
parce que j'aime bien tester quand même
deux trois choses
et la chaise gelé inclinée à 45 degrés
donc même consigne transformer moi ce
dessin quelque chose qui se déplacent
qui peut se déplacer et alors là j'ai
deux cas de figure j'ai eu deux cas de
figure qui m'ont enfin qui m'ont pas
traumatisé mais enfin qui m'ont
interpellé quand même parce que
généralement quand je fais la variante
je la fais juste après la première
le premier le premier test dont le
premier exercice
donc on peut dire que la personne est
déjà conditionné dit non tu sais tu es
bien tu avais répondu la consigne mais
essaye de sortir du cadre le prochain
coup et ne me fais pas une chaise avec
avec des roulettes
donc qu'est ce qui me fait une valise
qui se déplacent qui hockey la consigne
est toujours respectée mais on pourrait
peut-être trouvé quelque chose d'un peu
un peu différent et en fait là ces
personnes-là reste souvent bloqué avec
avec la notion de la chaise je vous ai
dit j'avais deux populations la deuxième
population qui est gelée eu alors je
sais pas il ya peut-être des chercheurs
mais c'était avec notamment avec
quelques chercheurs en asie où je me
suis retrouvé avec des personnes qui
étaient qui restait scotché devant le
dessin et au bon je les ai laissé deux
trois minutes comme ça puis au bout d'un
boutre minutes j'allais les voir je leur
dis mais il est où le problème
le problème c'est que je n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment la chaise qui en
écrit mme à givet lâché last chaises on
est vous êtes dans un dans un atelier
sur la créativité dont ok j'ai fait
exprès de vous dessinez une chaise mais
c'est plus une chaise sont des bâtons
essayé de me faire quelque chose ok donc
au bout d'un moment on se retrouve avec
une solution soit comme ça soit on a une
fusée soit on a faim on a des choses un
peu un peu diverses et variées même
exercice je le fais avec
donc je les fais avec des enfants et là
c'était un jeu marvel prénom mais
c'était une une élève de cp je crois
donc ça c'était il ya trois ans elle a
appris le dessin et puis boum
en trois secondes pareil on a fait ça
c'était l'époque d'angry birds donc
quand tu es là quand elle a vu le
l'espèce de chaises à vue les trois
bâtons 3 battant incliné poum est partie
directe dans son dans son monde et son
monde à elle à cette époque là elle
était dans les jeux en est ainsi de
suite
angry birds ce que je t'ai fait c'est
génial là je vous ai fait le dessin en
ligne rouge mais si je vous le fais en
noir
la chaise vous la voyez plus on part
complètement d'un autre chose donc par
rapport à tous et à ses différents
exercices on se rend compte que c'est
facile de d'accepter le par exemple là
je vous parlais des trois approches tout
à l'heure aux quais on est d'accord avec
les trois approches mais quand on les
implémente quand on essaye de les mettre
en place c'est pas évident parce que le
stress le stress de la chaise là j'en ai
eu quelques-uns j'ai notamment eu une
personne il ya six sept mois qui a pas
réussi à me faire un dessin
c'est à dire qu'elle est restée
tétanisée et donc on a rediscuté à
presse mais elle était tétanisé parce
qu'elle avait peur du regard de l'autre
sir mais si je loupe mon dos si je loupe
mon dessin qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui
va se passer on s'en fout il n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas de règle
donc c'est pas grave il n'y a pas de
bonne ou mauvaise réponse donc l'idée
derrière je vais je vais conclure là
dessus c'est ok transposer aux et est
supprimé je vais vous laisser sur cette
réflexion-là à partir de demain
après-demain prenez un de vos projets et
ou une situation personnelle essayer de
transposer dosés ou de supprimer quelque
chose et je vais donc je vais pas vous
demander de penser en dehors de la boîte
mais ce que je voudrais vous demander
c'est de créer de nouvelles boîtes de
craie de nouveaux cadres donc maintenant
c'est à vous de faire
merci